look around batcher in Paradise and what
do you see beside shirtless man well
drama drama drama and lots of it and the
most unbelievable moment was when
hothead Chad hold an insult at Sara that
was so cruel even by Chad standards and
Sara who stopped by our set today with
Bachelorette favorite Nick open up about
it for the first time the only person
who should be offended was you know our
Mimi Garmin Tsin you know I'm excited to
talk about bachelor in paradise because
it's only week two and there has already
been Pawlenty of drama of course
Otacon yeah yeah oh really what a tease
you are okay the biggest drama coming
from the first episode of course has to
do with angry Chad first thing that came
to your mind be really honest when you
heard him say these things to you it
hurt it was disrespectful it was way
below the belt he did actually apologize
somewhat we did an interview with him
entertained tonight did an interview
with him so I'd like to show you his
apology right now I'd love to see it I
can look I do feel kind of better I'm
not hear an apology in there Chad is
there an apology yeah I am sorry to them
for saying the things that I shouldn't
have said now whole apology to me is I
hadn't seen it I don't appreciate it
still I think if you really wanted to
apologize to me which he still should
and can it should be in person not only
that but like you're making fun of
something I have no control over like I
was born this way and if you want to
take stabs at people with disabilities
like that's gnarly
you were portrayed a little bit as the
villain do you have any empathy for Chad
at all
Chad was one of the few real villains
that we've had in bachelor history where
some of the things he did were really
just honestly kind of despicable as he
gets bad as he seems to be though yeah
Chad yeah yeah no he really is